I want to talk about enemies enemies are
what unites us in this country our
president knows this that's why he
targets our worst enemies like Broadway
shows and the occasional gold star
family the first step in fighting these
enemies is knowing who they are this is
the scary enemy number one the Olympics
I can't stand the Olympics they combine
the two things I hate most other
countries and curling those glorified
ice janitors are up to something and now
the Olympics are threatening our most
treasured pastime I'm talking about pole
dancing pole dancing
well now it's officially considered a
sport which means one day it could
possibly be part of the Olympics if I
get no other headline in we have to
discuss this I'm sorry you're gonna
segue from Jesus to toad anything what
would Jesus do would he pull dance at
the Olympics how dare you megyn kelly
Jesus would never pull dance at the
Olympics he doesn't have the core
strength have you seen that guy few too
many last suppers but bonus points for
bringing your own pole more importantly
give you points what points are due more
importantly pole-dancing is an American
institution that's why all the dancers
have names like Krystal and Svetlana we
can't let those Olympic globalist Sully
it's reputation
plus pole dancing is not a competition
there are no losers except for the
people who eat the shrimp cocktail at
the strip club those guys are really
rolling the dice the Olympics are trying
to steal our culture and the only way to
stop them is to support pole dancing
that is certified American you'll know
it when you see it yeah Olympics for
threatening my beloved pole dancing
welcome to the enemies list
boom now we've been under the thumb of
this next enemy for years president
Trump's election win anniversary is
coming up November 8th and some of the
president's critics plan to mark the day
by screaming into the sky helplessly to
express their anger
I have no problem with liberals
screaming it's their natural states like
a pig in mud or Mitch McConnell at frown
rehearsal no enemy number two is much
more nefarious the sky our sky has
betrayed us by giving liberals a
platform for their little shout party
but I've never trusted the sky it's
always changing it's where weather is
and ever since I saw The Lion King I've
worried about ghost animals spying on us
from their cloud homes off you old dead
lion I'll live my own life my own way
there's only one way to defeat this Airy
arch enemy ignore it completely bury
your head in the sand and I don't mean
metaphorically like usual I mean dig a
tiny hole grab a snorkel and get your
head right in there I always thought the
sky was up but apparently its left sky
welcome to the enemies list
this week's third enemy hits close to
home especially if you still live with
your parents
that enemy moms moms are always babying
us especially when we're babies but
sometimes they follow us into adulthood
takes Fox News's Jesse Watters
he's got the gravitas of Walter Cronkite
and the comedy chops of uncle Joey from
Full House look at what he has to deal
with from his mom all right as many as
you know my mom's liberal Democrat and
sends me texts during the show - could
she - critique me here we go what makes
you think it's appropriate to viciously
disparage insult and dismiss a member of
Congress how does that behavior
contribute to any sort of civil
discourse humility helps character
counts think about that yes yes and then
my favorite I am honestly concerned that
your colleagues have begun to roll their
eyes
come on Jessie's mom I rolling as a sign
of respect my staff does it every time I
open my mouth but Jessie I feel for you
here's some text my own Liberal Democrat
mom sent me just this morning you are
actively harming the country's political
discourse and I'm questioning every
decision I made as a parent there goes
mom again confusing actively harming
with you're doing a great job that I
love you this one's my favorite I no
longer recognize my own son moms am i
right
the point is moms are the enemy because
they weaken us they're the original
welfare state tempting us with unlimited
handouts for months in utero but not me
I'm a self-made man I was fed through a
separate umbilical cord that I built
myself when I was born when I was born I
tore it in half like a phone book and
taught myself to talk drive and hunt
small game
the point is mums are dangerous and the
only way to defeat them is to focus on
their natural enemies dad's no no no no
no no I don't mean those wimpy modern
dads who read to their kids and take an
interest in their lives I'm talking
about old school fathers the guys who
know what kids really need a healthy
stream of steady neglect punctuated by a
trip to the toy store once every four
years or so tell my old man brought me
up but I know he loves me because of how
often he almost says it so mom's for
trying to turn us into betas with your
incessant concern with who we are as
people you're going on the enemy's list
memorize that list opposition and
remember keep your friends close because
they're probably enemies in disguise